I have so many questions for you first
of all you have such an amazing voice
you've such a sexy raspy voice how did
you get that voice did you always have
that voice years and years of drinking
no um you know what it just kind of uh
you can stick with that it's riff you
why I just want to go I drink a lot ya
know it just kind of it's just kind of
now I'm all nervous
hopefully Marvis it's just us and a
giant fake moon huge bobblehead in the
back yeah we have a giant bobblehead of
me behind this that's to intimidate
guests before they come on I can feel
very natural yeah um you know I don't
know it it just sort of uh it just sort
of happened and I think it kind of
changed in high school and that was it
right does anyone else in your family
have that poise you know my daughter
does we're first one does really yeah
it's a baby which is like
no but she definitely she said and I
hear it now so now it's kind of a high
pitch so I do you think people are just
going what is he talking no that's a
very normal sounding voice yeah I'm
saying you have an amazing I love your
voice I really do and I do think it's
very sexy
and I want to ask you something Rizzoli
and Isles fans are just obsessed with
you two guys
and especially online you saw the stuff
online where they've made you a lesbian
couple yes that is why actually I got a
little fork limp because thank you very
much for making me feel very pretty
because I'm always the man in this
variant lesbionic relationship we have
we have some of the late they put up all
this kinds of up online well let's just
show one I think we have one right here
why do you think they they make you the
man in every swirl I don't see you that
way thank you
thank you very much because you know I
want to be sexy I want to be the girl
one time maybe twice you know but
literally like I'll open the door for
Sasha because that's what the man does
or you know I'll walk behind her but you
know do you think I've also noticed when
I watch the show that am I wrong am i
imagining things where they dress you
guys differently do they intentionally
dress matically different I mean it's
right for the character that's what a
lot of you know women detectives that's
what they wear they're very manly pants
and they're very sensible CV you can
tell them you know that Charlie's Angels
didn't let that get in the way you know
just seriously you can tell them that
they've make well this is what a real
detective would wear hot pants
yeah lingerie cops
didn't they do that wasn't that silk
Stalkings awesome Andy came up with that
title real fast there were 44 episodes
in all it should have been 45 well I
will talk to the producer if you want no
but that was very sweet of you did they
tell you to do that before make her feel
like a girl make her feel pretty about
your Angie Harmon you're one of the most
beautiful women I've talked to in the
history of me talking to women
my wife excluded
[Applause]
thank you very much that was close